salut aujourd'hui on est mercredi c'est
donc le jour des astuces de la semaine
je suis toujours chez tao et on est une
grande discussion hier soir entre mecs
et tous ont parlé parlé
tu peux être mentaliste du peuple
chinois du peut être ce que tu veux tu
mets deux mecs ensemble ça parle de
filles et comme la femme de ta vérité là
on a aussi parlé des relations homme
femme et je me suis dit c'est très bien
c'est un bon sujet pour mon thème du
mercredi aujourd'hui je vous donne 4
astuces pour savoir si vous plaisez à
quelqu'un en plus de ça ça fait quand
même pas mal de temps dans les
commentaires que vous me demandez des
astuces sur ce sujet là il ya aussi des
astuces de drag-queen vidéo plus tard là
dessus en fin du moi j'essaierai de le
faire je sais pas si je suis un très
compétent en la matière je pense pas
d'ailleurs mais ça n'empêche pas
d'essayer d'en bas je vous le précise
ans et pas des astuces là pour draguer
c'est des astuces pour voir déjà si
l'autre est réceptif en fait est ce qu
on s complet à quelqu'un est-ce qu'on
intéresse une personne est ce qu'on va
se prendre un râteau aime pas prendre
des râteaux astuces numéro une regard
vous devez regarder le regard de la
personne complet à quelqu'un on se rend
compte que les regards sont plus
appuyées ils sont plus insistants ils
sont plus longs la personne ne regarde
plus souvent elles cherchent un petit
peu nos yeux beaucoup plus que dans une
conversation normale
et si vous avez l'occasion encore une
fois la pupille allende ils ont plus la
pupille dilatée plus la personne est
intéressée par vous c'est un signe d'
intéressement c'est un signe
d'excitation la direction de la pupille
sans croire que vous exciter l'autre en
tout cas la personne vous trouve
attirante plutôt broncy astuces numéro
deux le ton de la voix qui utilisent la
personne qui vous parle que ce soit un
homme ou une femme encore une fois ça
marche pour les deux hommes à femmes
femme à homme et une femme femme on
utilise une voie différente avec la
personne qu'on a envie de charme et où
une personne qui nous plaît ou une
personne avec qui on est en couple
besoin d'un coup de main
ça va tout va bien tu me dis hein jamais
on parle comme ça
réalité jamais qu'on parle comme à ses
potes il n'y a qu'avec la personne avec
qui on est en couple qu'on parle comme
ça et de la même manière la personne qui
nous intéresse une personne qui nous
plaît on lui parle un petit peu
différemment donc observer comment la
personne parle aux hautes écoles mans
elle vous parle avouent essayer de voir
si elle prend une voix fusent et d'une
voix plus douce une voie la plus
charmante une voix de lover la presse tu
sais vraiment de comparer comment la
personne parle aux autres et comment
elle vous parle à ce troisième askus le
contact physique et on se touche et on
se cherche et on se renforce de touche
on se détrompent quand même on se touche
comme ça quand on tape sur le bras pour
dire une blague une personne à qui vous
plaisait pas chercher plus de contacts
les juges sûr que vous aussi
quand quelqu'un vous plaît vous cherchez
plus de contacts physiques des petits
rapprochement c'est pas grand chose mais
c'est plus fréquent que la normale alors
attention quand même à pas se faire des
films il ya des personnes qui sont très
très tactile tout le temps avec tout le
monde mais dans le jeu de la séduction
et de l'attirance en charge quand même
le moindre prétexte pour se rapprocher
de l'autre pour toucher un petit peu
l'autre pour créer des espèces de
connexion des sortes de connexion comme
ça et si vous voulez savoir si vous
plaisez à une personne vous pouvez
essayer de faire vous ce genre de
contact ce genre de rapprochement encore
une fois sans exagérer vous pouvez
jauger de sa réaction si c'est plutôt
positif négatif si la personnes
cherchent à fuir ce contact gentiment
élégamment ou pas ou si au contraire
elle y répond de la même manière ça vous
donne une bonne piste
quatrième et dernière asus a rejoint un
petit peu ce que j'ai dit précédemment
il faut absolument que vous analysiez
sept personnes dans ses relations avec
les autres et avec les autres à qui elle
a le même type de rapport c'est à dire
pas forcément avec ses amis mais avec
des gens qu'elle connaît au même niveau
que vous si cette personne ne vous
connais pas regarder comment à aller
avec les personnes qu'elle ne connaît
pas non plus ça vous évitera
d'interpréter maladroitement des signes
de politesse ou des signes de
gentillesse le gros problème qu'on soit
un mec ou une femme c'est de se faire un
film et de croire que la personne est
intéressée par dow alors c'est une
personne sympathique une personne
gentille une personne avenante
ça permet aussi de détecter dans
certains cas si c'est quelqu'un qui
drague tout le monde dans cette soirée
après ça peut vous intéresser mais il
n'y a rien
tel que le comparatif ne vous focalisez
pas complètement sur votre relation sur
vos échanges avec la personne en
question comparer vraiment vos moments
avec elle avec les moments qu'elle a
avec les autres personnes voilà c'était
quelques astuces du coeur aujourd'hui
lancé mercredi devant la fois que je
traîne un peu de ce sujet alors je fais
un petit peu court mieux on y reviendra
si ça vous intéresse vous avez juste à
me le dire dans les commentaires et puis
vous me faites savoir en laissant un
petit pouce en l'air
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas que demain je fais la faq
snapsan j'ouvrirai vos snapshot vous
avez encore jusqu'à 19h pour m'envoyer
un staff avec votre question avec une
photo avec ce que vous voulez ce qui
vous fait marrer
n'oubliez pas non plus de vous abonner
parce que c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez vous demain à
17 heures pour le prochain mentale blog
ciao